Let's now look at the solution for
Part 1 of this quiz, which is asking
when do these four instructions
dispatch and write their results.
We will do that one
instruction at a time.
The load is issued in cycle one.
It doesn't have any dependencies, but
we know that it cannot dispatch in
the same cycle when it's issued.
So it will dispatch in cycle two.
The load takes one cycle to do.
So it will write its result
in the very next cycle.
The multiplication instruction
is issued in cycle two.
It will dispatch in cycle three or
later because it cannot issue and
then dispatch in cycle two.
It will dispatch either
in cycle three or
whenever its operands become available
and because this multiply instruction
doesn't depend on the load here, it uses
F0 and F1, and the load produces F6.
That means that this instruction has all
the operands ready as soon as it issues.
So it can dispatch in cycle three.
It couldn't issue and then dispatch in
cycle two because of the same thing.
Issue and then dispatch in
this processor is not allowed.
The multiplication takes
five cycles to do.
So if it dispatches in
cycle three to execute,
it's going to be broadcasting
its result in cycle eight.
The add here is issued in cycle three,
so again,
it cannot dispatch in the same cycle,
but it could dispatch
in cycle four if all of its operands
are available in that cycle.
However, it needs F2 and F6.
These are produced by load and
multiply here.
So actually, it will not be able
to dispatch in cycle four because
the multiply result is only
available in cycle eight.
So what is going to happen to this
instruction is it's going to wait and
capture its result in cycle eight.
And then, it cannot capture and
then dispatch in the same cycle, so
it will dispatch in the very next cycle,
which is cycle nine.
Because this is an add and
has a latency of one cycle,
it will write its result in cycle ten.
For this add here,
it issues in cycle four.
It becomes eligible for
dispatch in cycle five if its
operands are ready, but they're not.
It needs the F2 produced
by the multiplication and
the F6 produced by this add.
That means that it will capture
its last missing operand
at the later of these two cycles,
which is cycle ten.
So in cycle ten, this instruction
captures its last missing operand,
which is F6.
And then, it cannot dispatch in
that same cycle because of this.
So it dispatches in cycle 11 and
finishes in cycle 12.
And this completes
the first part of the quiz.